Star Wars splatter art and a t-shirt commemorating
one of history's most lapidary quotes.
It's episode 25 of LÜT.
Navigate the web with glow-in-the-dark mouse
containing an actual spider.
And you can use a straw to drink juice right
out of a fruit, but this hand juicer turns
a fruit into a spray bottle for all your favourite
dishes.
Now go buy some top hats for your cat and
toast his style with a frothy beer that's
always foamy.
Japan Trend Shop brings us a gadget that with
a single click sends a rush of new bubbles
to the top.
You can say "I love you" in binary and then
snuggle up with your custom-made pillows.
PillowMob lets you upload a photo, crop it,
colour it, edit it and then receive a nice,
soft, cuddly, high-quality pillow, which is
apparently made by cats...?
Well, Neatoshop offers a unicorn-shaped pencil
sharpener, a beanie that makes you look like
a gory zombie, a soft, plush salami, ouchlets
for safety and a Tommy gun shaped purse.
I guess to carry around your spy video camera.
But you could be even more secret with a spy
camera hidden inside what looks like a phone
charger.
Evolution in New York sells a cute, stylised
tiger rug.
But if you have $3,000 and want a real animal
rug, they've got black bears, wolves and I'm
not kidding, zebras.
For a cool $12,000 you can get this.
Seriously.
I'm not lying.
Less real, but still macabre is this hollowed-out
skull USB hub.
You get 4 more ports and a skullball to keep
your stuff.
Similarly skeletory are these leg bones knee-high
socks, also available shorter, and Sock Theory
also has ones that lace up.
Happy socks and Converse shoes... socks.
Luna & Curious' animal mugs render each animal
half as a handle.
But if you're more interested in this end,
here's a coffee mug with a built-in secret.
As you sip away the Java, you reveal a perfect
little pile of poo.
When it comes poo at the office, avoid awkward
dumps next to your boss or dropped toilet
paper with this handy survival guide.
But in a worse-case scenario, make sure you've
got an emergency underpants dispenser.
Now, speaking of bathrooms, they are more
fun with giant googly eyes.
You can put these things on anything.
And they may not have meant it ironically,
but this book proves that dads are the original hipsters.
Of course, those gnomes and pink flamingos
they've got today... buy yourself a zombie
version for your own lawn.
And enjoy the sweetness of a 20-sided sucker.
The only luxury items more soothing are these
tequila ice pops, filled with real edible
gold flakes.
Now, your body can't really digest gold, so
save money and collect the flakes back after
sitting on your truck-hitched toilet seat-on-the-go.
In fact, why ever stop sitting?
These lazy football chairs let you try your
skills without working too hard.
Kick the ball with Kobi Levi's shark shoes
for him and her and illuminate the action
using a kit that helps you snap old light
bulbs into fun shapes around a new one.
Of course, why have real light when you can
have 8-bit light?
Painted on a canvas just for you.
Because then you can show your 8-bit life
with this necklace.
Or use one where the pendant swings on the
necklace, which is cute, but why the neck
a gemini?
Litter offers leg necklaces.
Well, they're guarder chains.
But here are some that attach to sunglasses
to give you a moustache.
Or a full biker beard.
Do you prefer air to metal inflatable beards,
because you can wash your body with soap containing
a foetus?
Look, just wash your head with some brain
soap.
Or brighten things up with a brain in a jar
candle.
You may wish to use a miniature MacBook pocket
mirror, but RedCandy has bigger ones.
The London underground, a razor blade or a
wiper blade to easily defog after a shower.
Oh and this one let's you compare your height
to celebrities.
Are you Snoop Dogg or Salvador Dali...?
...whose melting clocks could be yours with
this shelf clinking model.
It might be easier to just keep time on your
wrist with a watch made out of wood.
For every watch they sell the company plants a tree.
Now for your free thing, check out the wallpapers
Split Reason is offering.
I particularly enjoyed what the count must
see in the mirror.
And the simple fact that Particle physics
gives me a hadron.
Combine honeybees and boo to get boo-bees.
And always,
thanks for watching.